[Música]
les quiero contar que yo soy un artista
política
soy de una generación que creyó que el
arte iba a cambiar el mundo
así que desde que me pensé artista que
intento que mi práctica sea de
resistencia y de transformación
pero como que mi destino ha sido ser
artista por ejemplo mi mamá era pintora
y ella se murió cuando era muy chica
así que de alguna manera la pintura fue
la única opción que tuve fue como la
manera que yo encontré de estar cerca de
ella
y comencé a pintar a fin de los 80 y no
era un lenguaje como la pintura la
verdad que no me resultaba fácil pero
era lo que tenía a mano
y soy feminista y lo que más me gusta es
descubrir entender que yo lo descubrí
transitando en la práctica no
por ejemplo en los años 90 pintaba sobre
unas telas negras ropa interior femenina
con objetos de uso doméstico esas telas
iban colgadas sobre unos soportes de
madera en cruz y para mí eran como
grandes estandartes para una
manifestación de mujeres en la calle
después pinte todos los métodos
anticonceptivos femeninos
como que todo mi trabajo siempre está
instalado como toda la reflexión sobre
la violencia doméstica
pero no sabemos 90 la verdad que el arte
discutía otras cosas y mi trabajo no
circulaba así que yo tenía una gran
frustración
estaba enojada porque mandaba los
concursos de pintura y me rechazaban
sistemáticamente así que un día decidí
dejo el arte me voy a poner un bar en la
playa comencé a levantar mi taller
enojada y ordenaba poniendo algunas
cosas momentáneamente sobre la pared que
la sostenía con cinta de pintor
un día viene a verme un amigo
y me dice pero
y buena esa obra
yo me quedé como sorprendida cuando él
se fue me quedé pensando y fui a la
cocina abrió el cajón de los cubiertos y
saqué pinches
espátulas tenedores cucharas cuchillos y
repetí el gesto de sentarnos a la pared
con la cinta de pintor
ese gesto se convirtió en una obra que
formó parte de una gran instalación que
yo llamé material escéptico
como esos esos instrumentos eran como
eso era como un archivo para mí de
objetos de uso cotidiano que se
convertían en instrumentos quirúrgicos
para un aborto casero y clandestino
toda esa piensa reflexionaba sobre la
violencia en la ilegalidad del aborto
y yo soy en coma de todos modos sentía
que todo mi trabajo todavía estaba como
instalado en una especie de arte
grandilocuente pretencioso para mí ahora
entiendo como deconstrucción patriarcal
como en ese afán de ser es artista como
ideal
estaba externa a mí
y un día me pasó que de golpe empecé a
darme cuenta que estaba envejeciendo de
golpe
con 45 años me convertí en una mujer
menopáusica
se ha conocido una violencia totalmente
distinta como que desaparecía no sé
deseo logrado de una aparente fertilidad
útil
y dejaron de mirarme desaparecido de
todo posible horizonte
así que yo no sabía bien qué hacer con
eso la verdad
y tenía que reinventarme y decidí
y transitarlo obviamente en mi práctica
tenía que pensar en hacer una pieza una
obra que diera visibilidad estas nuevas
emociones así que decidí buscar mujeres
mujeres que en ese momento tenían más de
60 años que quisieran charlar conmigo y
que me ayudaron un poco a contar esto
que nos pasa
y mi obra dio otro giro totalmente
distinto
así que desde esa época que yo vengo
trabajando en la construcción de una
obra artística que se compone de
acciones de performance de vídeos y que
llamó escuela de envejecer que es donde
intento dar visibilidad a la violencia
del envejecimiento
lo que hago es trabajar con estas
mujeres que están jubiladas y que en la
actualidad están haciendo por ejemplo
todas esas actividades que quisieron
hacer cuando eran jóvenes esas
actividades deseadas y que no pudieron
porque tenían que trabajar cuidar hijos
no sé el marido pero por sobre todas las
cosas no pudieron hacerlo por todos los
prejuicios y prohibiciones que tenía
sobre todo esas épocas para con el
género
yo le pido a ellas que sean maestras de
esas actividades actuales deseadas
que se convierta realmente en esas
maestras de sus deseos frustrados que
son muy poderosas ahora
y lo que hago en una primera instancia
no sea como que se divide en dos partes
en una primera instancia me junto con
ellas en espacios íntimos de mucho
afecto y damos formas a estas acciones
con todas sus emociones y con la
intensidad de sus recuerdos por ejemplo
hace unos años me invitaron a una
tribunal en brasil
y trabaje
con una mujer que en ese momento tenía
87 años que se llama mariposa cata de
origen japonés
ella había tenido obviamente una vida
muy dura de mucho trabajo así que cuando
se jubiló no sabía qué hacer con su
tiempo libre
que hizo recurrir a sus deseos
postergados que obviamente eran el baile
y el canto
lo que hizo fue armar un cuerpo de baile
de danzas japonesas con sus amigas de un
club social todas que iban a un club
social
todos entre 70 y más de 90 años las
junto a todas y mariko les enseñaba
todas las coreografías que ella
inventaba y además diseñada todo el
vestuario que conocía y pintaba a mano
para cada una de sus amigas así que
cuando yo lo conocí le pedí por favor
que me enseñará a bailar
también cumplió como su sueño de
ser cantante y ella se convirtió en una
campeona regional de karaoke obviamente
le pedí por favor que me enseñe es
cantar karaoke
en una segunda instancia
estas estas acciones o esto que hacemos
en el espacio íntimo sale ya diseñado al
espacio público y damos esos talleres
performáticos a un público general en el
marco de una exhibición generalmente
en una institución artística
para mi escuela envejecer nos obliga a
subirnos a nuestros deseos
frustrados no hay manera de evitar eso
intento darle valor al capricho y al
fracaso como valores académicos como
saberes académicos también intentando un
poco discutir con el sistema del arte
que suele ser bastante autoritario y
prejuicioso con respecto al saber
siento que esta obra también propone
terminar con esa violencia que ha estado
en nuestra vida de mujeres desde siempre
y revisando también un poco toda mi
historia artística no me di cuenta que
sigo siendo esa artista
que todavía sigue intentando hacer una
práctica que sea de resistencia y de
transformación
bueno y ahora voy a compartir con
ustedes quiero compartir con ustedes y
que sean parte también un poco de mi
trabajo yo cumplí uno de mis sueños
también gracias a sakata yo
quería pertenecer siempre quise ser de
una banda de rock supongo que todos han
querido si alguna vez de una banda de
rock pero yo cumplí el sueño con mis
amigas artistas visuales todas hicimos
una banda de karaoke
nos llamamos las desesperadas por el
ritmo y hoy están acá van a subir al
escenario me van a acompañar y quiero
que todos se paren
parece todos parece todos arriba a todos
párense y vamos a cantar y bailar un
fragmento de una canción que nos gusta
mucho que se llama resistiré acá están
todas mis amigas
son muy grasas porque están acá y vamos
a cantar todos en un karaoke la canción
que se llama resistiré que supongo que
la conocen
[Música]
para tener
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la partida
cuando vea el mar coll
la soledad
cuando se me cierren las salidas
y la noche
cuando sienta bien
[Música]
cuando pues bueno
bien
pero no recuerdo
por qué
resistiré
o
[Música]
x
retire
y esto
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]